drone warfare is sold to us as clean
surgical and effective we act against
terrorists who pose a continuing and
imminent threat to the American people
but a new leak of classified information
published by the intercept confirms that
isn't quite the case first the
intelligence used to decide who to
target especially in countries where the
US isn't officially at war is frequently
based on flimsy evidence signals
intelligence usually electronic
intercepts or metadata from cell phones
and computers was used in more than half
of the drone killings in Yemen and
Somalia but the leak describes signals
intelligence as poor and limited in a
lot of cases there wasn't enough
information to confirm exactly who was
being tracked is that cellphone being
used by the target or by somebody else
90% of the people were tailing in these
drone strikes we have no idea who they
are
that gives lie to the pronouncements
that this is somehow surgical strategic
or targeted so why don't we hear more
about innocent people dying in these
strikes that might be because the US
government reports the death of any male
over the age of 15 killed in a drone
strike as an enemy killed in action
again even if they don't know who he is
during a year-long operation in
Afghanistan US drones killed over 200
people only 35 were actually targets but
every single death was classified as an
enemy killed in action
and despite what President Obama has
said many of those who are target's
don't seem to be immediate threats to
the United States drone warfare has
become so easy that it's frequently
being used against low-level operatives
there's a lot of debate around drone
killings but here's the bottom line
government officials are drawing up
secret lists of people to kill without
charge or trial let alone conviction so
are you comfortable with that drones
they buzz over the skies of Iraq
Pakistan or Yemen unmanned spying
missile launching